[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute startet eine neues Format.
Ich bin selbst ein bisschen aufgeregt, muss ich sagen.
Und heute habe ich meinen ersten Gast für mein Format.
Ich muss sagen, es ist ein richtig fresher Gast.
Man nennt ihn auch den König von Deutschland.
Er selbst ist Rapper
und natürlich auch Schauspieler.
Er hat ein eigenes Musiklabel und sogar einen Lieferdienst.
Und ich habe mir sagen lassen, dass er die Schlüsselfigur
oder eine Schlüsselfigur in der deutschen Hip-Hop-Szene ist
und mit beinah jeder großen Rapper-Legende in Deutschland
schon gearbeitet hat.
Herzlich willkommen, Eko Fresh!
>> EKREM: Wow!
Das ist ja eine Introduction hier!
Danke schön, Sally.
Ich bin ja selber total aufgeregt.
Weil ich sehe das immer nur in YouTube
und jetzt stehen wir hier selber in der Küche.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Ja. Und ich habe mir gedacht, komm,
ich lade dich jetzt echt mal ein
und dann machen wir einfach mal was Neues.
Also heute wird hier gekocht und gebacken.
Es gibt so ein paar Formate in diesem Format,
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: also ein paar Kapitel.
Und ja, das machen wir jetzt einfach.
>> EKREM: Sehr gerne.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Vielleicht kurz zu unserem Hintergrund,
warum wir uns auch kennen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich erinnerst,
aber vor sechs Jahren hattest du mir mal
sogar zum Geburtstag gratuliert in einem Video.
Weißt du das noch?
>> EKREM: Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
>> SALLY: Der Murat hat es mir vorhin gezeigt
und ich hatte es auch schon vergessen.
>> EKREM: Wow!
>> SALLY: Das war so ein kurzer Videoclip
und da hast du gesagt:
"Sally, vielleicht kann ich ja auch mal
bei dir ein Stück Kuchen probieren."
Ja.
>> EKREM: Ja, da siehst du,
ich mochte damals schon sehr gerne Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ich bin immer ein Leckermäulchen gewesen.
Ich weiß noch, da wart ihr mit der ganzen Family
auf einem Konzert in Heidelberg.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau!
>> EKREM: Das weiß ich noch.
Da, das war so der Moment,
>> SALLY: Da haben wir uns dann... Ja.
>> EKREM: den ich immer mit euch verbinde so.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Da haben wir uns persönlich kennengelernt.
>> EKREM: Genau, und kennen uns immer noch.
Und das ist Wahnsinn!
Danke, dass ich hier sein darf in deiner Sendung.
>> SALLY: Ja, gerne.
>> EKREM: Echt fresh!
>> SALLY: Und der Eko hat mich auch vor Kurzem
angesprochen nämlich wegen einem neuen Song.
Aber da reden wir später am besten kurz drüber.
>> EKREM: Gerne.
>> SALLY: Das ist nämlich eine richtig coole Aktion.
Und ich mache bei einem Musikvideo mit.
Ist schon ein bisschen aufregend.
Ja. Ich habe mir gedacht,
dass wir heute was kochen.
Bist du so ein Koch oder Bäcker?
>> EKREM: Eigentlich nicht, muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben.
Du, ich mache dir ein gutes Spiegelei mit Sucuk. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ah, das habe ich auch da.
>> EKREM: Das kann ich so und ansonsten halt...
>> SALLY: Sonst so Erfahrungen in der Küche?
>> EKREM: Ich repräsentiere eher so
den Mann zu Hause, der, sage ich mal,
ohne jetzt machohaft zu sein,
dir vielleicht Nudeln mit einem Steak reinhauen kann,
aber wahrscheinlich dann nicht mehr.
>> SALLY: Ach, komm, das klingt aber schon gut.
Ja.
Ich habe mir gedacht, weil wir ja beide
– du bist auch in Deutschland geboren, oder?
>> EKREM: Ja, natürlich.
>> SALLY: Also beide in Deutschland geboren,
aber türkischen Hintergrund,
also schon Deutsch-Türken, kann man sagen.
So zwischen beiden Kulturen aufgewachsen
oder mit beiden Kulturen aufgewachsen.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
wir machen was Deutsches und Türkisches vereint.
Und ich habe so ein paar Kommentare gesammelt
bei meinen Zuschauern.
Guck mal. Ich habe voll die Karten vorbereitet hier!
Achtung. Ich habe ein paar Sachen vorbereitet
und gesammelt bei meinen Zuschauern.
Ich habe nämlich gefragt:
"Was ist für euch eine typisch deutsche Küche?"
Was wäre für dich so typisch deutsch?
>> EKREM: Eisbein mit Sauerkraut.
>> SALLY: Das steht hier als Erstes, Sauerkraut.
Ja, so Spätzle.
>> EKREM: Spätzle.
>> SALLY: Es hat auch jemand Wiener Schnitzel geschrieben,
aber ich glaube, Wiener Schnitzel ist doch eher Österreich.
Aber ich zähle es trotzdem irgendwo so...
>> EKREM: Das esse ich übrigens für mein Leben gerne.
>> SALLY: Oh! Hätte ich das gewusst,
dann hätte ich Wiener Schnitzel gemacht.
>> EKREM: Das haben wir gestern gegessen.
>> SALLY: Lecker! Murats Lieblingsessen ist es auch.
So Königsberger Klopse.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Kennst du die?
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht? So
>> SALLY & EKREM: mit der hellen Soße.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
Und so typisch türkische Küche?
Was gibt es da, was du so kennst?
>> EKREM: Sucuk,
Lahmacun,
was wir ja unter türkischer Pizza alle kennen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Natürlich der Döner.
Das fällt ja allen wahrscheinlich als Erstes ein, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja. Was viele noch geschrieben haben:
Köfte, Kebab,
Sarma, gefüllte Weinblätter.
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und so als
– was ist für dich so der deutscheste Kuchen, den du kennst,
oder so ein deutscher Kuchen?
>> EKREM: Mh.
>> SALLY: Ich meine, die Konditorei ist ja schon
top in Deutschland, muss man schon sagen.
Also deutsche Konditorei und auch Bäckerei
ist echt krass, also ich finde die auch...
>> EKREM: Der deutscheste Kuchen?
Ein Bienenstich oder so vielleicht?
>> SALLY: Oh ja, stimmt.
Bienenstich, Frankfurter Kranz, so.
>> EKREM: Hm, hm.
>> SALLY: Was gibt es noch?
Es hat auch jemand Kaiserschmarrn geschrieben.
Da ist auch wieder so eine Sache:
Ist es Österreich? Ist es deutsch?
Man weiß es nicht.
>> EKREM: Ach so, ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
das kommt aus dem Schwabenländle.
>> SALLY: Ja, irgendwie.
Ich habe es auch.
Habt ihr das im Schwabenland, Sarah?
Nee, nicht?
>> SARAH: Bayern.
>> SALLY: Bayern. Ah, Bayern!
Stimmt, aus Bayern.
Ja, ist auch nah an Österreich.
>> EKREM: Da siehst du, da lernt man hier was dazu.
>> SALLY & EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Türkische Desserts?
>> EKREM: Türkische Desserts, die sind lecker.
Ich könnte jetzt wahrscheinlich keins mit Namen
– obwohl, Künefe.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Zu Künefe, da habe ich irgendwie so eine Geschichte dazu.
>> SALLY: Ich kenne da eine Geschichte.
>> EKREM: Ja, da gibt es eine Geschichte dazu. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, die wollen wir gleich hören.
>> EKREM: Alles klar, alles klar.
Aber die türkischen Desserts sind ultrasüß.
Ja, Baklava haben wir.
>> SALLY: Baklava, ja, ja.
Oder Katmer, das ist so aus der Pfanne
auch so ein Dessert mit Pistazie.
Ja. Und ich habe mir gedacht...
Ich habe jetzt ein paar rausgesucht
und dachte, wir verknüpfen die jetzt einfach miteinander
>> EKREM: Prima.
>> SALLY: und machen
Königsberger Köfte.
>> EKREM: Hört sich gut an.
>> SALLY: Dazu gibt es türkischen Reis ganz traditionell,
aber deutsche Kartoffeln.
Okay, das hört sich jetzt echt komisch an.
Aber deutsche Salzkartoffeln meinte ich.
Und danach gibt es einen Nachtisch.
Darüber können wir später noch reden.
Ja, Köfte. Hast du schon mal Köfte gemacht?
>> EKREM: Ich war dabei.
Ja.
Und ich habe auch bestimmt mal geholfen,
aber ich weiß den Ablauf nicht.
Den musst du mir sagen.
>> SALLY: Okay. Also...
>> EKREM: Ich helfe sehr gerne.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten.
Wir haben hier zum einen Hackfleisch.
Ich habe jetzt ein Rinderhackfleisch,
weil Lamm ist zwar auch so türkische Küche,
aber ich glaube, es wäre dann ein bisschen zu türkisch.
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen Toastbrot,
eine Zwiebel,
Eier.
Hier habe ich noch die Gewürze,
nämlich Kreuzkümmel
und Bergbohnenkraut,
etwas Salz und Pfeffer
und natürlich Petersilie,
was da dazu gehört.
Das muss übrigens da rüber.
Das gehört nämlich zur Soße.
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Dann türkischer Reis,
einfach so ein Rundkornreis.
Dann haben wir hier Şehriye.
Das sind so kleine Nudeln.
Und dann machen wir noch eine helle Soße
so wie bei den Königsberger Klopsen
mit Kapern und einer Mehlschwitze.
Hier noch Gemüsebrühe und Sahne.
Und dazu halt Kartoffeln.
>> EKREM: Ich liebe ja den türkischen Reis.
Ich liebe auch, wenn dann diese kleinen
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> EKREM: Nudeln da dazwischen sind.
>> SALLY: Okay. Ich hoffe, er gelingt mir.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, starten wir direkt mit Köfte.
>> EKREM: Sehr gerne.
>> SALLY: Wenn du willst, kannst du die Zwiebel
ganz fein schneiden.
>> EKREM: Das heißt
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: so, ja?
>> SALLY: Halbieren und dann so richtig fein.
>> EKREM: Okay. Okay.
>> SALLY: Machen wir jetzt erst mal so die Köfte-Masse.
>> EKREM: So?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und dann
– ah! Oh, warte mal.
Soll ich mit dir einen Zwiebelworkshop machen?
So: Wie schneidet man eine Zwiebel richtig?
>> EKREM: Ja, bitte.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und zwar:
Guck mal, das ist ja so die Wurzel.
Hier.
Und das hält die Zwiebel zusammen.
>> EKREM: Oh!
>> SALLY: Und dann kannst du nämlich zuerst
– also dort immer recht zusammen lassen,
gar nicht bis durch schneiden,
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: sondern so.
Und dann so ganz fein.
Dann so einen Tunnelgriff.
So.
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Guck, dann fällt sie nicht auseinander.
Und dann so.
>> EKREM: Okay.
Ich versuche es mal.
Ich gebe mein Bestes, okay?
>> SALLY: Ja, klar.
Und ich kann schon mal das Hackfleisch
hier in die Schüssel geben.
Die Rezepte findet ihr dann trotzdem später alle im Blog.
>> EKREM: Und die Wurzel kommt dann weg, ja?
>> SALLY: Genau, die Wurzel kommt dann weg.
>> EKREM: Okay, die habe ich ja jetzt hier schon
>> SALLY: Das macht nichts.
>> EKREM: blöderweise schon weggetan.
>> SALLY: Es sieht schon mal sehr, sehr gut aus.
>> EKREM: Ja, du siehst, ich bin da lernfähig,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: wenn ich was noch nicht kann.
>> SALLY: Ich bringe dir so ein paar Kniffe in der Küche bei.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dafür kannst du ja dir überlegen,
was du mir beibringen willst,
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: was ich von dir lernen kann.
>> EKREM: Alles klar.
Oh.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, ich hole mal ein Handrührgerät,
so für die Hackfleischmasse.
>> EKREM: Hu!
>> SALLY: Ja, ich habe ja vorhin kurz angesprochen,
du hast ja schon mit voll vielen Menschen
gemeinsam Songs gemacht, nicht?
>> EKREM: Auch, ja.
>> SALLY: Erinnerst du dich noch an die erste Kooperation?
Also mit wem hattest du das erste Feature?
>> EKREM: Oh! Es gibt so viele Sachen,
auch so Hip-Hop-intern,
ja, auch so Underground-Leute.
Ich bin ja schon, seitdem ich jung bin,
irgendwie da reingerutscht
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: und mache das eigentlich so
– es war das Erste, was ich je versucht habe,
und es hat sofort geklappt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> EKREM: Und da war ich gerade 16, 17.
Deswegen, also ich habe
– ich sage mal, mir erzählen manchmal Leute etwas,
woran ich mich gar nicht mehr erinnern kann.
Das ist wirklich so Teil meines Daseins so.
Mir ist etwas aufgefallen.
Nicht, dass ich von der Frage ablenken will.
Als ich hier reinkam, da sind die Fotos in der Lobby.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ja. Da ist ja der Sturmwaffel, nicht?
>> EKREM: Der war auf der gleichen Schule wie ich.
>> SALLY: Ach was?
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Kanntet ihr euch auch damals?
>> EKREM: Nee, der ist ja irgendwie zehn Jahre jünger
oder so.
>> SALLY: Ja, stimmt. Der ist, glaube ich, 89 geboren.
Oh, stimmt.
>> EKREM: Genau.
Aber der war auf derselben Schule.
Deswegen habe ich ja auch letztens drunter geschrieben,
als ihr gekocht habt:
"Ja, meine beiden Lieblingsköche so."
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja, der ist echt witzig, ein cooler Typ.
>> EKREM: Gut, mit dem habe ich jetzt nicht gerappt, aber...
Nee! Obwohl, mit dem habe ich auch gerappt.
Mit dem habe ich auch mal gerappt.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, dann müssen wir auch rappen später so was.
>> EKREM: Der hat doch auch so eine YouTube-Sendung.
Da haben wir gerappt.
>> SALLY: Mega!
>> EKREM: Na ja, du siehst, man rappt so
ziemlich viel, mit vielen Leuten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ich weiß nicht mehr den Allerersten.
>> SALLY: Aber...
>> EKREM: Kann ich mich nicht mehr erinnern.
>> SALLY: Aber du hast ja – warte mal.
Wenn du so 16, 17 warst, wann war das, in welchem Jahr?
>> EKREM: 1834.
Nein, Spaß. Spaß.
Also in den Neunzigern.
>> SALLY: Und Samira so
im Hintergrund.
>> EKREM: In den Neunzigerjahren so
habe ich so angefangen
und so richtig professionell wurde es dann
Anfang der Nullerjahre.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja, mega!
Ja.
Guck mal. Hier haben wir jetzt schon Zwiebeln drin
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: und die Eier.
Jetzt kannst du gern noch die Petersilie ganz fein hacken.
>> EKREM: Ganz einfach so, ja?
>> SALLY: Genau. Die Stiele würde ich jetzt
mal wegschneiden.
>> EKREM: Einfach wegschneiden?
>> SALLY: Genau.
Die hebe ich dann immer auf so für Smoothies.
>> EKREM: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Die sind nämlich sehr gesund, viel Vitamin C drin.
>> EKREM: Und jetzt auch ziemlich...
>> SALLY: Ganz fein. Ja.
>> EKREM: Fein, ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, aber, was ich mich jetzt echt frage,
wenn du schon so früh angefangen hast damit
und praktisch mit 16, 17 schon so in der Musikszene warst:
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hattest du jemals so einen Plan B?
Oder hast du so gedacht:
"Jetzt setze ich alles auf eine Karte und mache es",
was ja aber auch ein ziemlich enormer Druck ist?
>> EKREM: Hm. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob ich so viel darüber nachgedacht habe.
>> SALLY: Einfach gemacht?
>> EKREM: Ich war ja Schüler damals noch
auf dem Gymnasium.
Ich habe nebenbei gearbeitet in so einem Hip-Hop-Store.
Das war damals noch total neu.
Heute kennt man das ja,
diese ganzen großen Hip-Hop-Stores
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: mit den ganzen Klamotten und so.
Das war damals halt ein ziemlich neuer Laden.
Da habe ich halt so ein bisschen gejobbt,
neben der Schule ein bisschen Taschengeld verdient.
Und mein großer Traum war es, Rapper zu werden.
Und das war damals
– du musst dir vorstellen, das war ja noch kein Lebensplan,
den man so besonders seinen Eltern sagen konnte oder so.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ich finde, das ist jetzt gesellschaftsfähig
so auf eine Weise, ja,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: weil auch die Leute quasi gesehen haben,
man kann damit was machen.
Damals war es noch nicht so. Ja.
Und ja, aber kurioserweise hat das dann sofort geklappt.
Und es gab auch eigentlich kein Zurück,
weil es schon ziemlich früh auf ziemlich
– weiß ich nicht –
großer Ebene, auf großer Bühne war.
Und da, ja, dann...
Es gab eigentlich nie den Gedanken an Plan B.
>> SALLY: Okay. Es gab eigentlich nur diesen einen Weg
und ja...
>> EKREM: Genau, genau.
>> SALLY: Krass!
Guck mal. Jetzt verrühren wir das einfach.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und man kann es auch verkneten, aber
ich selbst mag das auch nicht so gern mit Hackfleisch,
muss ich echt zugeben.
Dann können wir das Handrührgerät nehmen.
So. Was können wir noch machen?
Oh, ich kann auch schon mal die Kartoffeln ansetzen.
Denn die Salzkartoffeln müssen einfach nur gekocht werden.
>> EKREM: Ich muss ja sagen,
zu Hause meine liebe Frau,
die versucht, gesund für uns immer zu kochen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Ich habe auch kürzlich aufgehört zu rauchen,
versuche jetzt so einen gesünderen Lifestyle,
den versuche ich einzuschlagen.
Ja, es war genug
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Rock ’n’ Roll sozusagen in meinem Leben so,
dass ich jetzt denke, ich muss, so lange es geht,
meine Familie irgendwie
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: mitbekommen. Ja.
Und ich bin ja jetzt erst quasi da angelangt,
wo ich all die Jahre hinwollte so.
Und jetzt muss ich eigentlich das genießen können.
Deswegen versuchen wir, uns gesund zu ernähren.
Ist bestimmt auch ein großes Thema bei dir,
gesunde Ernährung.
>> SALLY: Definitiv.
Und bei mir ist Murat auch so das Hauptproblem.
Ich glaube, so...
Jetzt weiß ich nicht. Ich kenne
– ich habe Mettbrötchen noch nie gegessen,
Aber isst man das so dann wahrscheinlich?
>> EKREM: Ich glaube, ja.
>> SALLY: Nicht? Das ist doch einfach so Hackfleisch
mit Zwiebeln und Gewürzen.
Ja.
So.
>> EKREM: Soll ich dir die Geschichte erzählen mit dem
>> SALLY: Erzähl!
>> EKREM: mit dem Künefe?
>> SALLY: Erzähl.
Denn ich muss sagen,
ich kannte die Geschichte nicht
und ich kenne sie immer noch nicht.
Aber eine Zuschauerin hat geschrieben als Frage:
"Kann er auch etwas anderes als Künefe?"
Und ich war so:
"Hä? Kann er Künefe?"
>> EKREM: Also ich habe...
Im Rahmen meiner TV-Aktivität,
ja, war ich schon das eine oder andere Mal
bei so Kochsendungen dabei. Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Und meistens ist das so,
dass ich das nicht so gut kann,
alle lachen ein bisschen.
Weißt du, ich bin dann so der Kandidat von denen,
der nicht so krass ernst genommen wird,
was aber dann nicht so schlimm ist,
weil es Spaß macht sozusagen. Ja.
Und dieses Mal wurde ich dann gefragt
und dann habe ich es mal ernst genommen,
ja, und habe gesagt: "Ich will das jetzt schaffen!
Ja, ich will das jetzt besser machen als der berühmte Koch."
Und was mache ich?
Natürlich habe ich dein Video dann angeguckt.
Weil ich sollte ein türkisches Dessert machen
und habe mich für Künefe entschieden
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> EKREM: und habe das anhand deines Videos
sozusagen gelernt.
>> SALLY: Cool!
>> EKREM: Und dann habe ich die ganze Woche
da bei mir im Dorf Künefe gemacht
und dann an die ganzen Nachbarn verteilt,
weil wir einfach zu viel hatten.
Aber es wurde auch wirklich immer besser.
Und dann
war dann diese Sendung
und ich war dann...
>> SALLY: Warst du beim Henssler?
>> EKREM: Beim Henssler. Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie...
>> SALLY: Grill den Henssler, nicht?
>> EKREM: Grill den Henssler. Genau.
>> SALLY: Ach, cool.
>> EKREM: Und ich weiß nicht...
Genau, ich war als Letzter dran
wegen
>> SALLY & EKREM: Dessert.
>> EKREM: Und der hat in dieser Sendung
haushoch verloren.
Weißt du, gegen beide.
Und ich war dann als Letzter dran.
Und ich schwöre dir auf alles,
– ja, ich will kein schlechter Verlierer sein –
dann haben sie ihm aus Mitleid Gleichstand gegeben.
Weil beim...
Er wusste ja...
Es ist ja auch ein bisschen gemein,
er wusste ja nicht, was Künefe ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Aber ist ja auch nicht schlimm,
es ist ja das Spiel.
Weil er ist ja ein Profikoch.
>> SALLY: Eben, er ist Profikoch.
>> EKREM: Das heißt, mein Künefe war perfekt!
So wie in deinem YouTube-Video.
Und er hat irgendwas erfunden so.
Weißt du so, da waren so wie so Maultaschen.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> EKREM: Weißt du?
Und die haben dem gleich viele Punkte gegeben,
weil sie ein bisschen Mitleid hatten,
weil er davor schon zweimal verloren hatte so. Ja.
Da war ich so gut!
>> SALLY: Dann wissen wir, wer der schlechte Verlierer ist.
>> EKREM: Aber insgesamt haben wir gewonnen.
Nein, der Henssler ist natürlich ein klasse Typ.
>> SALLY: Ja, eine coole Socke.
>> EKREM: Ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Ach, krass!
>> EKREM: Aber das war meine Chance! Weißt du?
Da konnte ich einmal besser sein so
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> EKREM: und dann war ich so
in diesen Umständen gefangen.
>> SALLY: Ach,
>> EKREM: Das ist meine Meinung. Ja.
>> SALLY: schade!
>> EKREM: Wer das nicht glaubt, der kann sich ja mal
mal die Sendung ansehen.
>> SALLY: Ich gucke es mir in der Mediathek an.
Auf jeden Fall.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Das sind jetzt die Köfte.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt nimmst du hier einfach ein bisschen Öl.
Mit dem Eisportionierer mache ich das voll gerne.
Ja, die Sendung, die gucke ich mir echt an.
>> EKREM: Also so?
>> SALLY: Das Künefe ist bestimmt perfekt geworden. Ja.
Genau. Und dann so zu Bällchen formen.
>> EKREM: Einfach so ein bisschen nehmen?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und dann legen wir sie auch hier so rein.
>> SAMIRA: Weil so ist es auch immer die gleiche Menge.
>> SALLY: Ja, so werden sie immer gleich groß.
>> EKREM: Rolle Köfte.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Denn wir wollen ja Königsberger Klopse/Köfte machen.
>> EKREM: So, ja?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Noch ein bisschen fester so zusammendrücken,
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: damit die uns nicht auseinanderfallen.
Ich habe ein bisschen Respekt davor.
>> SALLY: So. Ich schmeiße schon mal die Pfanne an.
Okay.
Ich habe ja
>> EKREM: Ja?
>> SALLY: meiner Community verraten, dass du heute da bist.
>> EKREM: Oh!
>> SALLY: Und ich habe Fragen gesammelt
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: und würde die dir einfach mal vorlesen, okay?
>> EKREM: Ja, sehr gerne.
Hu!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also los geht's.
"War es dein eigener Wunsch,
einmal mit Sally backen zu dürfen?"
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Nee, ich habe ihn gezwungen.
>> EKREM: Nein, also total freiwillig.
Also, wie wir schon gesagt haben,
wir kennen uns eigentlich schon so lange
und haben das jetzt zum ersten Mal gemacht.
Das ist doch cool.
>> SALLY: Was für eine Frage!
Jetzt steht da hinten der Murat so mit der Pistole.
Er muss das machen.
"Was ist dein Lieblingsgebäck?"
>> EKREM: Lieblingsgebäck?
Mh.
>> SALLY: Torte, Kuchen, süßes Teilchen.
>> EKREM: Ich mag Käsekuchen gerne.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ich habe heute...
Ich habe heute Kuchen für dich gebacken.
>> EKREM: Ja?
>> SALLY: Und ich habe den besten Käsekuchen
der Welt gebacken,
>> EKREM: Echt?
>> SALLY: den San Sebastian Cheesecake.
>> EKREM: Hör auf! Echt?
>> SALLY: O mein Gott! Als hätte ich es gewusst!
Oh, das ist eine coole Frage!
"Wenn du deinen Namen als Rapper heute ändern müsstest,
wie würde er lauten und warum?"
>> EKREM: Wahrscheinlich würde ich
mit dem bürgerlichen Namen kommen,
ja, weil das wahrscheinlich eher jetzt zu meinem Dasein als
– weiß ich nicht –
Unternehmer und
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Schreiber und so weiter
passen würde wahrscheinlich, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ich meine, Eko Fresh, da warst du ja richtig jung,
als du das damals gemacht hast.
>> EKREM: Genau, genau, genau.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Genau.
Kann ich mir solange die Hände hier waschen?
>> SALLY: Ja, klar. Komm, wasch sie dir.
"Bist du abseits deiner Karriere schüchtern?"
>> EKREM: Ja.
Ich muss auch sagen, früher habe ich das viel mehr genossen,
im Mittelpunkt zu stehen, als ich gerade damit anfing.
Mittlerweile ist das so, dass ich das
– ich weiß nicht –
in gewissen Phasen ganz gerne mag,
aber eigentlich nicht immer.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Oh ja, das ist eine coole Frage!
"Wie kamst du auf die Idee mit dem Lieferservice?"
Weil ich habe bei dir auf Instagram gesehen,
dass du jetzt einen Lieferservice hast.
>> EKREM: Ich habe jetzt einen Lieferservice. Genau, genau.
Liefertüte.de.
Ich weiß nicht, wie 30-Jährige Werbung machen,
aber das gibt es ja im Moment eh nur regional bei uns in Köln.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ich hoffe aber, bald schon in ganz Deutschland.
Und das haben Jungs gemacht, die ich von früher kenne.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Die haben früher
eine Videoproduktionsfirma gehabt.
Und mit denen hatte ich damals
viele meiner Musikvideos gemacht.
Und ich mochte den Chef immer sehr gerne.
Ich hielt ihn auch immer
für einen schlauen Kopf und guten Unternehmer.
Und dann kam er irgendwann zu mir,
hat mir diese Idee unterbreitet, also so einen Pitch gemacht.
Und ich war halt direkt
begeistert und dachte, das ist eine gute Idee. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist echt cool.
"Was ist dein Lieblingskuchen
und könntest du ihn selbst backen?"
>> EKREM: Käsekuchen, habe ich ja schon gesagt.
Ich könnte den wahrscheinlich nicht selbst backen.
Vielleicht könnte ich meiner Frau zur Hand gehen
oder, ja, mit Rezept.
Dann gucke ich mir halt wieder eine Woche lang
dein Video dazu an so.
Dann versuche ich das.
Vielleicht klappt das dann irgendwie mal.
>> SALLY: Also den San Sebastian Cheesecake,
den kannst du hinkriegen.
>> EKREM: Ja?
>> SALLY: Weil das sind nur so fünf, sechs Zutaten,
alles verrühren, in die Form, fertig.
>> EKREM: Ich habe ja letztes Mal gesehen:
Da hat meine Frau einen New York Cheesecake gebacken
und das war dann in so einer Backform drin
und da drumherum war Wasser.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Also es sah schon sehr aufwendig aus.
>> EKREM: Also da wäre ich, glaube ich, raus.
>> SALLY: Der wird so mit Dampf gebacken.
Oh!
Okay. Wer hat diese Frage gestellt?
"Wird es ein Musikvideo mit Murat in der Hauptrolle geben?"
>> EKREM: Ja, klar!
Wir haben gerade noch darüber gesprochen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Der Murat ist ein cooler Typ.
Ey, der könnte auch aus der Rap-Welt kommen.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
>> EKREM: Ein cooler Dude.
>> SALLY: Sarah...
Sarah genießt den Dreh heute, nicht?
>> EKREM: So wie
Kerl.
>> SALLY: "Kannst du etwas Kurzes
übers Kochen oder Backen rappen?"
>> EKREM: Ich würde sagen, das können wir gleich machen.
Weil du hast ja gesagt, ich soll dir dann etwas beibringen
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: als Gegenleistung.
Und dann würde ich sagen,
dann machen wir einen kleinen Rap.
>> SALLY: Okay. Und ich muss dir sagen so als Hintergrund,
also Sarah ist eine hervorragende Sängerin
>> EKREM: Wow!
>> SALLY: und ich bin eine hervorragende Nicht-Sängerin,
aber ich liebe Karaoke.
Und manchmal, wenn wir Rezepte probieren,
dann singen wir über das Gericht,
was wir da gerade probieren.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Käsekuchen, Buchteln.
Uns fällt dann immer was ein.
Ja, cool! Ich lerne heute rappen.
>> SAMIRA: Ich möchte Rapperin werden.
>> EKREM: Du möchtest Rapperin werden?
Krass!
>> SALLY: "Welchen Beruf würdest du heute ausüben,
wenn du jetzt nicht Rapper wärst?"
>> EKREM: Also das, das war
quasi, habe ich eben schon gesagt, das Erste,
wonach ich gefragt hatte.
Abseits dessen habe ich eigentlich nur
in diesem Klamottenladen gejobbt. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, das ist auch das,
was die wenigsten Jugendlichen
oder Kinder vielleicht auch wissen,
dass, wenn man Musik macht,
und dass viele Menschen in der Öffentlichkeit
– dass sie eben auch gut in der Schule waren
und auch eine abgeschlossene Schulausbildung haben.
Und ich glaube,
>> EKREM: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: wenn man heutzutage Kinder und Jugendliche fragt:
"Was wollt ihr denn mal werden?",
die sagen nicht mehr Schauspieler,
die sagen alle YouTuber, Rapper.
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Aber ich versuche, dem immer entgegenzuwirken
und auf meinen Social Media
irgendwie einen guten Einfluss auf die Jugend zu haben.
Ich habe auch erst kürzlich eine Single darüber rausgebracht.
Ich möchte die Jugend irgendwie ermutigen.
>> SALLY: "Du bist anders", nicht?
>> EKREM: "Du bist anders".
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ich möchte die ermutigen
und gleichzeitig denen auch eine Welt öffnen.
Ich will ja, dass die was auf die Beine stellen, ja,
und dass sie etwas machen, was denen gehört,
ein Geschäft aufmachen oder sonst was.
Von so was bin ich mega Fan.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Da könnte ich stundenlang drüber reden.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, das machen wir jetzt
als letzte Frage vielleicht.
Oh!
Oh nee. Okay, drei letzte Fragen, die drei letzten.
>> EKREM: Alles klar.
>> SALLY: "Was war bisher dein größter Patzer
bei einem Live-Auftritt?"
Ist dir mal was passiert?
So gestolpert, Text vergessen, Hose gerissen?
Wie bei Lenny Kravitz übrigens.
>> EKREM: Mir ist...
Ich bin ja gefühlt mein ganzes Leben irgendwie auf der Bühne.
Mir ist schon häufig was passiert.
Ich bin schon häufig umgefallen.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> EKREM: Einmal habe ich mich übergeben.
Sorry, dass ich das hier sage.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Auf der Bühne?
>> EKREM: Ja, auf der Bühne.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
>> EKREM: Es haben aber nicht alle mitbekommen,
weil da gibt es ja diese großen Boxen.
Und dann bin ich schnell hinter eine da gehuscht.
Und das haben nur die mitbekommen,
die da auf der Seite standen.
>> SALLY: Ach du meine Güte!
>> EKREM: Also dadurch, dass halt ich so oft
auf der Bühne war in meinem Leben,
ist natürlich die Chance dann größer,
dass was Dummes passieren kann.
Ich bin aber generell so ein bisschen tollpatschig auch,
muss ich zugeben.
>> SALLY: O Mann!
Bei so einer Frage, auch so: "Was ist dir peinlich?",
ist es bei mir auch immer so:
Mir fällt nichts ein, weil
mir ist auch nichts peinlich. Weißt du?
Mir war das voll peinlich!
Das sage ich: "Murat, was hast du an deinem Handy?
Da klebt hinten was."
Das, aber das...
Okay, das...
Da kommen wir echt nicht raus.
>> EKREM: Ich finde ja auch,
man muss über sich selber lachen.
>> SALLY: Ja, eben. Eben.
>> EKREM: Das ist eine Tugend,
die wird total unterschätzt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Weil damit kommst du immer weiter,
mit einem Lächeln.
>> SALLY: Die Frage habe ich vorhin nicht ganz verstanden.
Aber dann habe ich sie gegoogelt
und dann habe ich sie verstanden.
>> EKREM: Ah ja.
>> SALLY: "Wie ist dein Verhältnis zu Andrea Berg?"
>> EKREM: Ich finde Andrea Berg toll.
Ich habe damals mal ein Lied von ihr gecovert
und so ein bisschen umgedreht,
aber alles mit so einem Augenzwinkern.
Wie gesagt,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: ich bin so ein Rapper, ich
nehme mich manchmal nicht so ernst.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ich kann auch mal eine lustige
Version machen, eine lustige Aktion machen.
Da habe ich kein Problem mit.
>> SALLY: Sehr cool.
Und die allerletzte Frage ist:
"Was ist der beste Schulspicker-Tipp?"
Oh, Samira, kannst du bitte weghören?
>> EKREM: Der Schulspicker-Tipp?
Ich habe natürlich nie gespickt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hast du damals mal abgespickt?
>> EKREM: Ich denke, ja.
Ich denke, mit irgendwelchen Zetteln
wurde da schon rumhantiert manchmal.
>> SALLY: Ich meine: Wer hat das nicht gemacht?
>> EKREM: Ja, ja. Und hin und her gegeben.
>> SALLY: Man darf sich halt nicht erwischen lassen.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, hast du dann auch schon mal gespickt?
>> SALLY: Ich brate jetzt die Köfte an.
Vielleicht.
Und wenn man es macht,
darf man sich nicht erwischen lassen.
>> EKREM: Das stimmt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
So. Jetzt braten wir die mal an.
Ich weiß, Königsberger Klopse, die werden nicht angebraten,
die werden gekocht.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann sind die so weich.
Aber ich denke mir so:
Weiches Essen können wir essen,
wenn wir irgendwann alt sind
und die Zähne nicht mehr so...
>> EKREM: Das sind jetzt Königsberger Köfte.
>> SALLY: Das sind jetzt Königsberger Köfte
und die werden angebraten.
>> EKREM: Normalerweise sind ja auch Köfte
so eher oval, richtig?
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
>> EKREM: Ich verstehe jetzt.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, der Reis.
>> SALLY: Oh ja, der Reis. Stimmt.
[Musik]
Gut. Dann kannst du die auch gern rausholen.
>> EKREM: Ja, die sind schon
– wollte ich gerade sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja, die sind schon recht dunkel.
Ich mache jetzt hier schon mal den Reis .
Da sind ja immer diese kleinen Nudeln mit dabei.
Oh, ich brauche noch einen Löffel.
>> EKREM: Geil, hier mit der Kelle, ey, die Sally hat.
Echt das beste Equipment, ey.
>> SALLY: Ja. Dann haben wir die Köfte jetzt raus.
Dann kannst du hier direkt die Soße machen
und zwar Butter rein und Mehl.
>> EKREM: Das Stück hier?
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> EKREM: Komplett rein?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Butter ist bei mir
– die zwei lachen schon.
Aber ich habe immer ungelogen
fünf Kilo Butter
in meinem Kühlschrank mindestens.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja, das auch rein.
>> EKREM: Ich dachte, jetzt kommt "in der Westentasche"
oder so.
>> SALLY: Wenn ich könnte, würde ich es auch mitnehmen.
O Gott! Da gibt es echt ein peinliches Erlebnis
von Murat.
Also, wo wir vorhin bei peinlichen Erlebnissen waren:
Wir waren ins Kanzleramt eingeladen
>> EKREM: Oh!
>> SALLY: in Berlin, ja,
zur Ministerin für Digitalisierung,
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: zur Dorothee Bär.
Und ich war schon aufgeregt.
Weil, ich meine, so in den Bundestag und Kanzleramt
– keine Ahnung –
geht man ja auch nicht jeden Tag, nicht?
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt kannst du da schon die Brühe reingießen.
>> EKREM: Die hier, ja?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Komplett rein?
>> SALLY: Ja. Und gern dabei rühren, dass es nicht so klumpt.
>> EKREM: Ach so. Gut.
>> SALLY: Und morgens haben wir halt gefrühstückt im Hotel.
Und
der Murat ist so einer, der läuft nicht so gern oft ans Buffet.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, der packt sich den Teller so voll,
dass er einfach alle Hände voll hat.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und, weil er dann keinen Platz mehr
in der Hand hatte, hat er sich die Butter
einfach in die Hosentasche gesteckt.
So in der Verpackung. Weißt du?
Dann sind wir im Kanzleramt.
Und wir mussten hinrennen,
weil das Taxi ging nicht durch.
Da war Stau. Dann war die Straße gesperrt.
Ich wollte nicht zu spät kommen.
Also sind wir hingerannt so die letzten drei Kilometer.
>> EKREM: Moment. Es war diese abgeschlossene Butter,
die es im...
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Diese 10-Gramm-Päckchen da.
>> EKREM: Alles klar. Okay. Gut.
>> SALLY: Und der hat die wohl für uns,
für den ganzen Tisch mitgenommen,
also so drei, vier Päckchen.
Wir rennen zum Kanzleramt, so drei Kilometer.
Ich, voll aus der Puste.
Keine Ahnung.
Dann waren wir bei der Dorothee.
Wir wollten Bilder machen.
Und da habe ich gesagt:
"Murat, mach auch mal ein Bild von uns."
Und er prahlt immer mit seinem Huawei, weil er sagt,
das Huawei macht bessere Bilder als das iPhone.
>> EKREM: Ja. Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann habe ich gesagt:
"Mach halt mit deinem Huawei."
Dann holt der das Handy raus,
voll verschmiert.
Und ich so: "Hä? Was hast du da? Ist das Kaugummi?"
Mir war das voll peinlich!
Das sage ich: "Murat, was hast du an deinem Handy?
Da klebt hinten was."
Und der hat sich vor Lachen nicht mehr gekriegt
und hat erzählt,
dass er die Butter in der Tasche vergessen hat
und im Taxi drin saß.
Ach Gott, haben wir gelacht!
>> EKREM: Das sind dann so Momente,
genau, wo es drauf ankommt,
und dann passiert einem
>> SALLY: Ach!
>> EKREM: so was, echt.
>> SALLY: Die Doro,
die hat sich nicht mehr gekriegt vor Lachen.
>> EKREM: Ich finde das auch echt witzig.
>> SALLY: Das war so typisch Murat. Ja.
>> EKREM: Ja, schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Nicht?
>> EKREM: Ja, voll.
>> SALLY: Jetzt habe ich noch ein bisschen so Zitronensaft.
Ich glaube, das passt.
Und dann kannst du die Köfte dazu geben.
>> EKREM: Einfach rein, ja?
>> SALLY: Ja. Vorsicht, dass du dich nicht verbrennst.
Genau, mit dem.
Und dann können wir nämlich die Köfte,
die Königsberger Köfte,
schön in der Soße ziehen lassen.
Der Reis ist auch gleich gar und ich würde sagen,
wir machen unser Battle.
Denn in meinem neuen Format gibt es auch ein Battle,
einen Contest.
Ich muss dazusagen, ich weiß selbst noch nicht,
was auf uns zukommt.
Denn ich habe das das Team vorbereiten lassen.
Und da kommen wir jetzt dazu.
>> EKREM: Alles klar.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Herzlich willkommen zu dem Battle
zwischen Ekrem Bora, genannt Eko Fresh,
und Saliha Özcan, genannt Sally.
>> EKREM: Gut!
>> SALLY: Unsere Quizmasterin hier.
>> SARAH: So. Der Josh und ich,
wir haben uns Spiele überlegt,
dass ich nicht so allein dastehe.
Die erste Challenge wird sein:
Ihr wiegt
– nee, ihr wiegt nicht!
Ihr müsst ohne Wiegen
100 Gramm Mehl in die Schüssel füllen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> EKREM: Gut.
>> SARAH: Viel Erfolg!
>> EKREM: Also das ist total unfair,
weil ich damit nie
irgendwas zu tun habe.
Aber ich versuche es. Ja, ich versuche es jetzt mal.
>> SALLY: Habt ihr absichtlich
unterschiedliche Schüsseln genommen?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh.
>> EKREM: Also die Schüssel ist schon...
>> SARAH: Dass ihr auch nicht abschauen könnt.
>> EKREM: Da ist schon das Gewicht
quasi dann abgezogen, ja? Bei der Schüssel, ja?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> EKREM: Das heißt...
>> SALLY: Ach so, ihr wiegt es dann wo rein, nicht?
Okay.
>> EKREM: Also da muss nur 100 Gramm Mehl rein, ja?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> EKREM: Unabhängig von der Schüssel, ja?
>> SARAH: Ja, genau.
>> EKREM: Okay, okay, okay.
Na gut.
>> SALLY: Was ich schon mal gut finde:
Sie haben Mehl 405,
Mehl 405,
also die gleiche Mehltype.
>> SARAH: Natürlich!
>> EKREM: Ah! Das ist hier 405, ja?
>> JOSH: Wir sind perfekt vorbereitet.
>> SARAH: Ja.
Hast du was anderes erwartet?
>> EKREM: Also das ist hier 1.000 Gramm.
Das heißt,
hiervon ein Zehntel, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Okay, okay, okay.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> EKREM: Ein Zehntel hiervon.
Mh.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Das ist tatsächlich schwierig.
Also viele denken jetzt vielleicht:
"Oh, die Sally, die kann das ohne Waage."
Aber ich habe auch mal gegen
Sturmi
>> SARAH: Sturmi, gell?
>> SALLY: ohne Waage gekocht
– gebacken.
>> SARAH: Oh, da hat Zucker gefehlt.
>> SALLY: Da hat richtig Zucker gefehlt.
>> MURAT: Bei Mehl macht es nicht viel aus.
Bei Koks wäre das schlimmer.
[Lachen]
>> SALLY: Ja, bei Mehl...
>> EKREM: Da hat der wieder die Sprüche raus hier.
>> SARAH: Ich bin gespannt.
Ich glaube, sie hat ein bisschen zu viel.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube auch.
>> SARAH: Aber ich bin auch schlecht darin.
>> EKREM: Ja, aber, wenn ich das hier jetzt wiege, ja,
und das muss ein Zehntel davon...
>> SARAH: Aber die Schüssel.
>> EKREM: Das ist ja nicht mal
>> SALLY: Ja, das...
>> EKREM: Das ist ja ein Prozent davon.
Also ich habe zu wenig.
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm, hau es rauf.
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Soll ich meins reinschütten?
>> SARAH: Ja, ihr schüttet eures rein.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: 94.
>> SARAH: Sorry, ich kann dir...
>> EKREM: Ich brauche gar nicht antreten.
>> SARAH: Ich kann dir schon sagen, das ist
>> EKREM: Ich sage dir...
>> SARAH: zu wenig.
>> EKREM: Ja. Ja.
>> SARAH: Aber sag mal, was du schätzt,
was das jetzt ist.
Ich schätze, das sind...
Keine Ahnung.
>> SALLY: 40 oder so.
>> EKREM: Ich glaube, nicht mal wahrscheinlich.
>> SALLY: Oh, 43.
>> EKREM: Da siehst du.
>> SARAH: Wir brauchen so einen Siegerton.
D-d-d-d-da-daa!
>> SALLY: Den nehmen wir auf.
>> SARAH: Saliha Öczan 1 zu 0.
Ding-ding!
>> EKREM: Also du kannst ja mit mir folgendes Spiel spielen.
Du kannst einen Beat laufen lassen
und ich kann schätzen, wie viel bpm das ist.
Ja, das ist dann wieder mein Gebiet.
>> SALLY: Was ist bpm?
Was ist bpm?
>> EKREM: Wie die Geschwindigkeit...
>> SALLY: Beats per minute.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> EKREM: Beats per minute,
wie die Geschwindigkeit davon ist. Ja.
Aber ich kann leider nicht so abschätzen, wie viel Mehl das ist.
>> SARAH: Die nächsten Challenges sind weniger mehlig.
>> EKREM: Alles klar. Alles klar.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: So.
Die nächste Challenge wird sein:
[Musik]
An einem Stück
aufs erste Mal
das Haus vom Nikolaus zu zeichnen.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Oh, er ist...
Moment. Hier habe ich Papiere vorbereitet.
Und los!
An einem Stück. Es geht nicht um Zeit.
>> EKREM: Gleichzeitig, oder?
>> SARAH: Ja, gleichzeitig.
>> SALLY: Also dieses "Das ist das Haus vom Nikolaus"?
>> SARAH: Genau. Es geht nicht um Zeit.
Ihr müsst es nur am Stück schaffen.
>> EKREM: Das ist das Haus vom Nikolaus.
>> SARAH: Oh! Aber du warst schneller.
>> EKREM: Aber...
>> SALLY: Okay, bei ihm sieht es besser aus.
>> EKREM: Ach so, kam das auf Tempo an?
>> SARAH: Uh, was ist mit deinem Dach passiert?
>> SALLY: Ja, es sieht nicht...
>> SARAH: Okay. Nein.
>> SALLY: Ich habe ein modernes Dach.
>> SARAH: Sie hat ein abgeecktes Dach.
Das ist ganz...
>> SALLY: Ich habe eine Schräge zu viel.
Hä? Warum habe ich da so eine...
Ah, ich weiß warum.
Ich war
Ja, okay, ich war falsch.
Weil ich habe so, so, so gut angefangen
und dann bin ich so in die Ecke
und dann wollte ich runter
und bin dann doch noch mal...
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Ein Punkt für dich.
>> EKREM: Okay. Dann haben wir ja 1:1.
Wow! Das ist ein spannendes Spiel.
>> SARAH: So. Nicht meine Challenges anschauen!
>> EKREM: Nein, ich gucke hier diesen...
Hier ist ja ein Tischtennisball.
Ich komme.
>> SARAH: So.
Die nächste Challenge wird sein:
Wer schafft es von euch beiden
länger die Luft anzuhalten?
>> SARAH & EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Und
jetzt.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also, wenn ich noch ein paar Sekunden länger,
dann
– oh, wow! –
wäre es mir schwarz geworden.
>> SARAH: Ja, das wollen wir nicht.
>> SALLY: Du!
>> SARAH: Du warst voll in deinem Element.
Oh, er ist immer noch!
O Gott!
>> SARAH: 2 zu 1.
>> EKREM: Okay, okay.
>> SARAH: Ding-ding!
[Musik]
So.
Die nächste Challenge
sind zehn Fragen.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Und der, der die meisten davon beantworten kann
– ich lese sie ganz schnell vor.
Der Erste, der antwortet, kriegt den Punkt.
>> SALLY: Ist das Allgemeinwissen?
>> EKREM: Okay. Reinrufen?
>> SARAH: Ja, reinrufen.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Es ist Allgemeinwissen.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> SARAH: Allgemeinwissen, aber auch
nicht Allgemeinwissen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: So. Wir haben hier süße, kleine,
rosa, weiße Schmetterlinge vorbereitet.
Der, der die richtige Antwort hat,
nimmt sich bitte den Schmetterling weg.
>> SALLY & EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Sonst kann ich nicht mitzählen.
>> SALLY: Sagst du dann: "richtig"/"falsch"?
Ach so. Was ist aber jetzt, wenn er zum Beispiel
oder ich, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel was rausrufe,
aber es ist falsch?
>> SARAH: Dann hat er noch Zeit, es richtigzustellen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Aber du hast dann schon...
>> SALLY: Ich habe dann meine Chance verspielt.
>> SARAH: Genau.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Und wenn es niemand...
>> SALLY: Also nur einmal antworten.
>> SARAH: Genau, nur einmal antworten.
Überlegen.
Und wenn es jemand falsch
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: hat, kriegt
– also, wenn es beide falsch haben, kriegt keiner einen Punkt.
>> SALLY & EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Ja, es ist schwierig.
So. Und los geht's.
So schnell wie möglich antworten.
Wer singt den Song "Roller"?
>> SALLY: Apache.
>> SARAH: Richtig.
Wie heißt unsere Bundeskanzlerin?
>> SALLY: Merkel.
>> SARAH: Richtig.
Wie viel sind 40% von 110?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: 44?
>> SARAH: Ja, richtig!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Welche Gebühr muss man
für das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen bezahlen?
>> EKREM: GEZ.
>> SARAH: Richtig!
Mit wem ist Jay-Z verheiratet?
>> EKREM & SALLY: Beyoncé.
>> SALLY: Aber du warst zuerst.
>> SARAH: Oh, er war früher. Richtig.
Aus wie vielen Spielern besteht eine Fußballmannschaft?
>> SALLY & EKREM: Elf.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Oh, das war...
Das war...
>> EKREM: Du warst zuerst. Du warst zuerst.
>> SARAH: Den geben wir mal kurz niemandem.
Wie bezeichnet man einen luftleeren Raum?
>> EKREM: Vakuum.
>> SARAH: Richtig.
>> SALLY: Oh, ja.
>> SARAH: Handymarke: Nicht Birne, sondern?
>> SALLY: Apfel. Apple.
>> SARAH: Ja, richtig.
Warte. Aber es war falsch.
>> JOSH: Ja, es war falsch.
>> SALLY: Scheiße!
>> SARAH: Ja, es war falsch.
>> EKREM: Wieso denn?
>> SALLY: Ja, weil meine erste Antwort...
>> SARAH: Sie hat Apfel gesagt.
>> EKREM: Ja, aber das ist ja die deutsche Version.
>> SARAH: Ja, das war der Trick
>> SALLY: Ah! >> EKREM: Okay, okay.
>> SARAH: hinter der Frage.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich darfst du es jetzt sagen und...
>> SARAH: Nee, eigentlich darfst du es sagen.
>> EKREM: Nein, machen wir weiter.
>> SALLY: Doch.
>> EKREM: Das ist doch unfair.
>> SARAH: Sag es.
>> EKREM: Nein, ich sage das jetzt nicht.
Das ist zu unfair.
>> SARAH: Oh, er ist richtig kollegial.
>> SALLY: Voll fair!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Jetzt.
>> SARAH: Musikalische Tonleitern beginnen mit dem Ton?
>> EKREM: Do.
>> SALLY: C.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> EKREM: Ach so. Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> SARAH: Ja, richtig.
>> SALLY: Echt? Ich habe die Musikfrage? O mein Gott!
>> SARAH: Richtig.
>> EKREM: Ich habe dieses
>> EKREM & SALLY: Do Re Mi.
>> EKREM: Ich bin so bescheuert!
Okay, weiter.
>> SARAH: Und die letzte Frage:
Was ist die Hauptstadt von Spanien?
>> EKREM: Madrid.
>> SARAH: Richtig.
So. Wer hat mehr Punkte?
>> EKREM: Gleich viel.
>> SALLY: Beide vier.
>> SARAH: Aber das zählen wir jetzt einfach
auf den Punktstand dazu.
>> EKREM: Gleich viel, Digger.
Es läuft!
>> SARAH: Digger, wuh!
>> SALLY: Es läuft.
Apfel!
>> SARAH: So. Also wir sind hier bei 6
und bei 5.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Cool.
>> EKREM: Boah!
Hey, du warst ja wie aus der Pistole geschossen.
Du kannst so was gut, Mensch!
>> SALLY: Ah, nee.
Ich habe immer gedacht, ich blamiere mich bei so was.
>> SARAH: Seid ihr bereit
für die nächste Challenge?
>> SALLY & EKREM: Ja.
>> SARAH: Die nächste Challenge ist Küchentennis.
>> EKREM: Oh!
[Musik]
>> SARAH: So. Wir kommen zur nächsten Challenge.
>> EKREM: Oh ja.
>> SARAH: Wir haben kurz umgebaut.
Ich habe den Murat dazu geholt.
Der unterstützt mich.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich bin der Idiot, der die Bälle einsammelt.
>> SARAH: So. Eure Aufgabe wird sein:
Ihr habt hier schöne, süße, kleine Tischtennisbälle
und die lasst ihr zweimal aufhüpfen
und müsst
in den Emaillebecher reintreffen.
>> SALLY: Hätten wir nicht
eine Emailleschüssel nehmen können?
>> SARAH: Nein.
Sonst ist es ja langweilig.
>> SARAH: Ich habe es probiert.
>> EKREM: Also eins, zwei, rein, nicht?
>> SARAH: Es ist machbar.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Nach wie vielen Versuchen, sage ich jetzt nicht.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Habt Spaß.
>> EKREM: Okay. Ladies first.
>> SALLY: Zweimal aufdopsen und dann da rein.
>> SARAH: Ja, wir machen abwechselnd.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Einmal du, einmal du.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Und wer das als Erstes schafft, kriegt den Punkt.
>> EKREM: Okay. Und das muss da drinnen bleiben?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> EKREM: Okay, okay, okay.
Und das erste Mal muss es hier auf.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> EKREM: Und das zweite Mal hier.
Okay, alles klar. Alles klar.
>> SALLY: Oh ja, übertreibt es halt gleich
mit eurer Challenge hier.
Okay, ich probiere es einfach.
>> MURAT: Bin ich froh, dass du durch das Backen
berühmt geworden bist.
[Lachen]
>> SALLY: Oh, das war gut!
Oh!
Jetzt schießt er da rüber.
Ah.
>> EKREM: Ah, zu viel.
>> SALLY: Ah, das ist aber auch gut.
Das macht man doch so.
>> EKREM: Nee.
Ja, das kann noch ein bisschen dauern, Freunde.
>> SALLY: Die folgenden Sendungen
>> MURAT: verschieben sich um eine Stunde.
>> SARAH: Wie bei...
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> MURAT: So einfach geht es.
Wieso lasst ihr mich das nicht machen?
>> EKREM: Soll ich machen? Oder...
>> SARAH: Ihr könnt einen Joker wählen, Murat.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Au ja.
>> EKREM: Ich glaube, du bist.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> EKREM: Da hast du jetzt echt genau die beiden Richtigen.
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt kommt gleich der Hauptschüler
und macht das kurz.
Soll ich es mal kurz machen?
>> SALLY: Ja, komm, Murat.
>> SARAH: Komm, Murat. Du bist der Joker.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott! Das gibt es doch nicht!
>> SALLY: Wenn er es jetzt reintrifft,
dann mache ich mir echt Sorgen um mich.
>> MURAT: So.
Ich zeige es mal, wie es der Hauptschüler macht.
[Applaus]
>> EKREM: Wuh!
>> SARAH: Hey!
>> MURAT: Sehr schön.
[Applaus]
Du hast Glück, dass du den richtigen Mann geheiratet hast.
>> SAMIRA: Hallo?
>> MURAT: Danke schön!
Es war schön.
Habe ich jetzt gewonnen?
Ich glaube, das Spiel habe ich gewonnen jetzt. Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Du hast gewonnen.
>> EKREM: Du hast die ganze Challenge jetzt gewonnen.
>> SARAH: Ihr könnt den Punkt an Murat geben.
Ihr habt euch
>> SALLY: Fertig?
>> SARAH: nicht so gut geschlagen.
Deshalb gibt es jetzt eine alles entscheidende Challenge.
>> EKREM: Wow!
>> SARAH: Wer schlägt Ela im Ezyroller-Fahren?
>> SALLY: Kennst du Ezyroller?
>> EKREM: Nee.
>> SALLY: Ela ist echt Profi.
>> SARAH: Du lernst es jetzt kennen.
>> EKREM: Okay.
Ist das so?
>> SARAH: Nee.
>> SALLY: Mit den Füßen.
>> EKREM: Ach so. Okay.
>> SALLY: O Gott!
>> EKREM: Boah, ich bin so schlecht bei so was!
Ich lege mich ganz bestimmt voll hin, ey.
>> SALLY: Okay. Dafür wechseln wir kurz das Studio
und gehen raus.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: So. Wir sind jetzt hier draußen.
Wir haben uns umgezogen.
Und die Ela ist schon in voller Montur.
Den Helm kriegt jetzt der Ekrem.
>> EKREM: Oh, ja.
>> SALLY: Safety first.
>> EKREM: Danke. Safety first.
>> SARAH: Dass nichts passiert.
Ich ziehe euch eine Linie.
Und das ist der Startpunkt.
Und dann fahrt ihr einmal
um den Kürbis rum
und wieder hierher.
>> EKREM: Alles klar.
>> SARAH: Und wer zuerst wieder hier ist,
hat gewonnen.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SARAH: Okay?
Aber so.
Ela, du hattest gerade
– was ist dein Statement?
>> ELA: Ich mache dich fertig!
>> SARAH: Oh!
Oh, okay.
>> EKREM: Hu!
>> SARAH: Was sagst du dazu?
>> EKREM: Ich glaube, das wird eine harte Gegnerin.
Und ich glaube, die kann das richtig gut.
Aber wir gucken mal.
>> SARAH: Ich bin gespannt.
One,
two,
three,
go!
[Musik]
>> EKREM: Du kannst das aber gut! Hör mal!
Mann! Wie schnell bist du denn?!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ach.
Ela!
Wuh!
[Lachen]
Ela, wie fühlen Sie sich nach dem ersten Sieg?
>> ELA: Also ich habe schon ein paar Mal gewonnen.
[Lachen]
>> SARAH: Okay. Wie fühlen Sie sich nach dem
>> EKREM: Ich schaffe es!
>> SARAH: Sieg gerade eben?
Gut?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SARAH: Sehr gut.
Oh!
>> EKREM: Wuh!
>> SALLY: Oh! Wer kommt denn da?
>> SARAH: Mit einer Zeit von einer Stunde.
>> EKREM: Ja! Ich bin Zweiter!
>> SARAH: Eine Stunde und zehn Sekunden!
Wuh!
Eko Fresh!
>> EKREM: Ja!
Meine Güte!
Die konnte das so schnell!
Es war unglaublich! Ja.
>> SARAH: Aber ich muss sagen, das Pink,
der Helm steht dir gut.
>> EKREM: Das matcht auch irgendwie mit meinen Klamotten.
>> SARAH: Ja, voll.
>> EKREM: Als hätte ich es gewusst.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> ELA: Das passt mit dem Pink, Rosa.
>> EKREM: Richtig, richtig.
>> SALLY: Ojemine!
>> EKREM: Siehst du? Und mit Mode
kennst du dich auch noch aus. Hör mal.
>> SARAH: Ja, ja, sie ist ein Talent.
>> SALLY: Darf ich dir mein Handy anvertrauen?
>> EKREM: Ein Multitalent.
>> SARAH: Das wollte ich sagen.
>> EKREM: Brauchst du den?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Safety first.
>> SARAH: So.
>> EKREM: Also es ist echt
– es ist auf jeden Fall schwieriger, als man denkt, ja,
wenn man es noch nie gemacht hat.
Ja. Und die Kleine, die geht ab wie eine Rakete.
Die kann das so gut.
>> SALLY: Ach!
>> SARAH: Wie viele Punkte hat er bekommen?
>> ELA: Null.
>> SARAH: Tja...
>> ELA: Also einen halben Punkt.
>> EKREM: Einen halben habe ich?
>> SARAH: Gibst du ihm einen halben Punkt?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> EKREM: Okay. Das ist nett von dir.
>> SARAH: Das ist ein Ehrenpunkt.
>> ELA: Ich mache dich fertig!
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Puh!
>> MURAT: Mit den langen Beinen
müsstest du eigentlich schneller sein, gell?
>> SALLY: Es ist tatsächlich schwieriger, glaube ich, weil...
>> ELA: Weil du mehr Gleichgewicht...
Weil du...
>> MURAT: Ela, willst du der Mama
ein bisschen Vorsprung lassen?
Nur ein bisschen, okay?
Okay?
>> SALLY: Nein, nein! Wir starten fair. Komm.
Ich kriege das hin.
>> SARAH: Gegen ihn hat sie auch
keinen Vorsprung gelassen.
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, gegen die Ela gewinnt niemand.
>> SALLY: Nee, echt nicht.
>> MURAT: Es gibt keinen Mensch, der Ela...
>> SALLY: Und es sieht so aus, als hätte der Eko
extra langsam gemacht, aber es war nicht so.
>> EKREM: Nee, es war wirklich nicht so.
>> MURAT: Zwischendrin habe ich mal gedacht,
der Eko hat einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Aber die Ela...
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm jetzt! Kommt!
>> EKREM: Mir geht es top.
>> SARAH: Jetzt sind wir mal gespannt.
[Musik]
One,
two,
three,
go!
>> MURAT: Mario Kart, los!
[Musik]
He! Was ist denn mit dir los? Was ist denn das?
>> SARAH: Sally!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich versuche! Ich gebe doch mein Bestes!
Ah!
>> SARAH: Schneller!
[Musik]
>> EKREM: Hey, die geht so ab!
>> SALLY: Ah!
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Oh, oh!
Oh, oh!
>> MURAT: Die lacht sich tot, die Sally
– die Ela.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> SARAH: Die Ela, die guckt nach hinten beim Fahren.
[Musik]
Die ist schon so routiniert.
>> MURAT: Komm! Super!
Fein!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Mein Gott!
>> SARAH: Hey!
>> EKREM: Prima!
>> SARAH: Ela hat gewonnen.
>> SALLY: Die Schuhe rutschen.
Achtung!
>> SARAH: Jetzt schiebst du es auf die?!
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
He! Du bist über all die Pflanzen gefahren!
O mein Gott! Geh raus!
Sally ist ins Kiesbett gefahren.
>> SARAH: Geht es dir gut?
>> ELA: Hey, was geht denn jetzt?
>> MURAT: Du hast sie fertig gemacht, Ela.
>> SALLY: Och, Ela!
>> SARAH: Ela, du bist der Star. Check ein.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Wir haben die Punktzahl.
zu 5.
Unser Gast ist der Sieger.
[Applaus]
Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh!
>> EKREM: Mega!
>> SARAH: Ich hoffe, dir hat es gefallen.
>> EKREM: Ja, ey! Das war eine tolle Spielshow.
>> ELA: Sarah?
Wie wäre es, ich suche mir
einen Partner aus?
>> SARAH: Einen Partner?
>> SALLY: Ich habe auch was gelernt fürs Leben:
>> ELA: Einen, der gleich groß ist wie ich.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und jetzt gegen Papa. Los!
>> SALLY: Mach bei keinen Challenges mit.
>> EKREM: Ich war bei einigen Spielshows dabei.
Ja, aber hier in Sallys Show,
da ist der Spannungsbogen einfach nicht mehr auszuhalten.
Ja.
Und gerade das hier, das ist echt ein witziges Spiel gewesen.
Ja, weil, wer denkt schon,
dass er gegen so ein kleines Mädchen nicht antreten kann?
Und auf einmal kann die das so gut!
Ey, das ist ja Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Achje!
[Musik]
[Applaus]
>> SALLY: Also ich bin ja ein recht fairer Verlierer.
Also herzlichen Glückwunsch
>> EKREM: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: zum gewonnen Battle.
>> EKREM: Ja, zum Glück gewonnen. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich dachte auch die ganze Zeit so,
ja, eigentlich sind die Karten gut,
aber dann nö.
Ist auch okay. Man muss auch mal verlieren können im Leben.
Wir waren jetzt nicht mehr direkt in der Küche,
sondern haben zwischendrin noch was gefilmt.
Und zwar habe ich euch ja am Anfang schon erzählt,
dass ich in seinem neuen Musikvideo mitgemacht habe.
Und
im Prinzip war es ja so:
Du hast mich gefragt, ob ich mitmachen will,
hast mir das Thema gesagt und ich war sofort:
"Ja, bin ich dabei."
>> EKREM: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Weil es einfach
was Emotionales ist, aber auch was sehr Ernstes.
Denn es geht ja um Gewalt gegen Frauen, nicht?
>> EKREM: Richtig.
Also erst mal zunächst danke, dass du das hier
erst mal erzählst hier nebenbei,
nebenbei, wo die Butter hier brutzelt.
Und vielen, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du dabei bist!
Das bedeutet mir echt viel.
Das Thema ist ein megawichtiges Thema.
Ich habe dir ja eben schon gesagt
oder wie du ja auch schon sagtest,
ich rappe ja häufig über so soziale Themen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Häufig auch im Zusammenhang mit Integration,
weil das natürlich irgendwie Sinn macht,
ja, weil das aus mir raus kommt.
Aber auch das Familienthema ist ja für mich äußerst wichtig,
gerade jetzt, wo ich eine Familie habe.
Ich sehe ja den Kleinen gerade.
Da geht mir mein Herz auf.
>> SALLY: Die spielen die ganze Zeit da hinten so schön!
>> EKREM: Ja, es gibt einfach nichts Schöneres auf der Welt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Insofern war ich bereit, dieses Thema,
dieses schwierige Thema anzusprechen, weil ich glaube,
über häusliche Gewalt wird nicht genug geredet.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch eher so ein Tabuthema.
Und ich denke auch, dass Frauen, die davon betroffen sind
– ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es mit Männern ist,
aber ich glaube, in der Regel, statistisch gesehen
sind wahrscheinlich mehr Frauen und Kinder betroffen.
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich glaube, dass es bei Frauen auch,
ja, auch so ein Schamthema ist, nicht?
Man schämt sich dafür, wenn man Gewalt erfährt.
Und ich glaube, es muss ja nicht mal nur
Gewalt, also körperliche Gewalt sein,
es kann ja auch psychische Gewalt sein,
>> EKREM: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: dass man einfach...
Und
ich denke, man redet nicht drüber,
weil es einem auch peinlich ist natürlich.
Ich meine, wenn man dann Familien draußen
auf dem Spielplatz sieht, im Schulhof oder
beim Elternabend und die sind alle megaglücklich,
stellt man sich, glaube ich, nicht gern als Frau hin und sagt:
"Ja, ich werde zu Hause geschlagen."
>> EKREM: Ja, das hängt wahrscheinlich auch viel zu viel
dran hinten sozusagen an so einer tiefen Entscheidung.
>> SALLY: Ja, klar.
>> EKREM: Und meistens kann es ja auch sein,
dass das an dem Selbstbewusstsein liegt,
dass man sich eben nicht traut, eine...
>> SALLY: Oder Abhängigkeit.
>> EKREM: Eine Abhängigkeit, richtig.
Dass man sich nicht traut, eine Beziehung zu beenden.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Und insofern ist dieser Song da,
um einfach den Frauen, die so was erfahren,
eine Stimme zu bieten,
um zu sagen: "Du bist nicht allein auf der Welt",
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: also eine Kraft zu geben.
Und wenn das auch nur darin resultiert,
dass eine einzige Frau sich denkt: "Hey..."
>> SALLY: "Jetzt habe ich Kraft gewonnen."
>> EKREM: Ja. Dann ist ja schon
der Auftrag sozusagen erfüllt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Und ich habe jetzt ein paar befreundete
Damen, Powerfrauen richtig, ja,
aus der Medienwelt,
die ich jetzt über all die Jahre kennengelernt habe,
danach gefragt.
Und ich danke dir, dass du dabei warst.
Das ist für mich eine mega Ehre.
>> SALLY: Ja, für mich ist das voll die Ehre,
dass ich dabei sein darf.
Ich finde es echt cool.
Ich bin auch mal gespannt drauf, wer noch alles mitmacht.
Und ich denke, die Botschaft dahinter
ist auch wirklich vor allem an euch Frauen zu Hause
und auch an die Kinder,
die Gewalt zu Hause erleben,
sei es psychische Gewalt, sei es körperliche Gewalt:
Ihr seid wirklich nicht alleine.
Ihr könnt euch auf jeden Fall auch melden.
Und es gibt ja auch ganz viele Hilfsorganisationen.
>> EKREM: Richtig.
>> SALLY: Das Bundesministerium, das
>> SALLY & EKREM: Familienministerium.
>> EKREM: Richtig. Genau.
>> SALLY: Mit denen hast du das ja gemacht,
die Initiative gestartet.
>> EKREM: Richtig. Und ich suche
– wir können ja mal hier den Link einblenden.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> EKREM: Das ist da natürlich eine Stelle,
wo man sich melden kann, wenn man so was erfährt,
und es wird einem geholfen.
Ich glaube, da sind wir in Deutschland
sehr gut dran, was die ganzen Initiativen betrifft.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EKREM: Hm.
>> SALLY: Auf jeden Fall. Ein sehr ernstes Thema.
>> EKREM: Also ich danke euch für die Aufmerksamkeit
für dieses ernste Thema.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht so ablenken.
Wir sind ja hier in einer schönen,
gemütlichen Gesellschaft gerade.
>> SALLY: Nee, aber das ist auch wichtig.
Also bei uns ist es ja echt auch so,
dass Sallys Welt so ein bisschen so zum Abschalten
vom Alltag ist.
Aber ich bin auch immer dafür,
da ernste Themen anzusprechen.
>> ELA: Mami?
>> SALLY: Ja, Mäuschen?
>> ELA: Hast du mein Video gesehen?
>> SALLY: Ich habe dein Video noch nicht gesehen.
Aber ich gucke gleich, – okay? – wenn wir fertig sind.
>> ELA: Hm.
Mami?
>> SALLY: Warte kurz.
Ich muss sowieso schnell was holen da hinten.
>> ELA: Das ist auf Instagram.
>> EKREM: Die ist so süß, die Kleine.
>> SALLY: Auf Instagram?
Ich gucke gleich, okay?
>> ELA: Du musst gucken.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja, und das
– der Song, der kommt ja auch jetzt gerade raus.
>> EKREM: Genau.
>> SALLY: Und den könnt ihr euch auf jeden Fall anhören
und auch teilen.
>> EKREM: Richtig.
>> SALLY: Denn ich muss sagen,
das ist ein Thema, was natürlich verbreitet werden muss.
>> EKREM: Richtig.
Darum geht es ja, dass es so viele wie möglich hören,
damit es nicht lange ein Tabuthema bleibt.
>> SALLY: Ganz genau.
[Musik]
Josh, ich bin jetzt schon ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ich mache jetzt bei einem Musikvideo mit.
Und dann ist es auch noch so voll der krasse Songtext
gegen Gewalt gegen Frauen.
Okay.
Und ich muss dann praktisch einfach synchron mitsprechen?
>> EKREM: Einen Satz.
>> SALLY: Einen Satz.
>> EKREM: Komm. Das schaffst du!
>> SALLY: Das schaffe ich. Komm. Ich schaffe es.
>> EKREM: Es ist ein wichtiges Thema. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
[Musik]
>> EKREM & SALLY: Das ist doch keine echte Gewalt.
Ich bin nur von der Treppe gefallen.
>> EKREM: Genau.
Mega! Du machst das mega!
Versuch, dich in die Lage zu versetzen von jemandem,
der so was Schreckliches eigentlich
>> SALLY: Ich könnte weinen.
>> EKREM: sich einredet.
Ja, ich weiß, du bist ein impulsiver Mensch, nicht?
Ein empathischer Mensch.
Denk mal so: Wie am Ende
müsste eine Frau sein, die das sagt? Ja.
[Musik]
Achtung.
>> EKREM & SALLY: Das ist doch keine echte Gewalt.
[Musik]
Ich bin nur von der Treppe gefallen.
>> EKREM: Yes!
[Musik]
>> EKREM & SALLY: Das ist doch keine echte Gewalt.
Ich bin nur von der Treppe gefallen.
[Musik]
>> EKREM: Yes!
Danke schön!
Hey, danke, dass du das gemacht hast!
Ey, das ist
– voll cool hast du das gemacht. Danke!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Guck mal hier.
>> EKREM: Da bist du hier die Kadayifs am Anbraten.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich sehe schon.
>> EKREM: Das kenne ich ja noch, ja,
>> SALLY: Das darfst du gerne machen.
>> EKREM: als alter Künefe-Profi.
>> SALLY: Ela, gib das mal dem Ekrem abi.
Ja.
>> EKREM: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe hier schon den Kaiserschmarrn drin.
Ich habe leider eine schlechte Nachricht.
Denn ich glaube, ich habe
den Reis versalzen und verkocht
– wollte ich dir jetzt mal an der Stelle sagen –
und
>> EKREM: Ach, das passiert dir auch, ja?
>> SALLY: vielleicht den Kaiserschmarrn angebrannt.
>> EKREM: Das passiert dir als Megaprofi
auch manchmal, ja?
Das ist ja so wie, wenn ich
>> SALLY: Vielleicht.
>> EKREM: neben dem Takt rappen würde, nicht?
>> SALLY: Würdest du sagen
– ach, komm. Es geht noch. Das sind Röstaromen.
>> EKREM: Ja, das ist kein Problem.
>> SALLY: Das geht! Ach, Kaiserschmarrn,
der wird jetzt sowieso gleich gezupft in der Pfanne.
Ich hole mal kurz meine Gabeln.
Irgendwie haben wir kein Besteck mehr hier.
Guck mal.
Doch, das sieht doch gut aus.
Das schalte ich dir mal kurz höher.
Dann könne wir das ein bisschen karamellisieren.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann geben wir noch Feigen dazu.
>> EKREM: Hier dazu, ja?
>> SALLY: Die sind aus unserem Garten.
>> EKREM: Einfach so reinschütten?
>> SALLY: Warte noch kurz, bis die ein bisschen braun sind.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die habe ich einfach getrocknet.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: So getrocknete Feigen.
Und dann können wir gleich alles probieren.
>> EKREM: Prima!
>> SALLY: Ja, ich hatte ja eben jetzt schon so leichte, kleine
– okay, war das eben jetzt Sprechgesang
oder war das Rap, was ich da mitgesprochen habe?
>> EKREM: Ja, Rap ist ja eigentlich Sprechgesang.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht? So...
>> EKREM: Das war schon Rap.
Ich bin ja der Meinung, jeder kann rappen.
Ja, das Einzige ist: Du musst
bei der Wahrheit bleiben.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> EKREM: Und wenn du als Sally starten willst, rappst,
dann musst du auch rappen wie Sally.
>> MURAT: Kurz, Entschuldigung.
Aber vergiss bitte nicht, dass sie Grundschullehrerin ist.
Ich habe wenig rappende Grundschullehrerinnen gesehen.
>> EKREM: Vielleicht haben wir jetzt
die erste Deutschlands. Ja.
Und auch da muss man dann bei der Wahrheit bleiben.
Zum Beispiel kannst du rappen:
"Yo, ich bin die Sally.
Ich war mal Grundschullehrerin." Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Yo, yo, yo.
>> SALLY: Komm, wir machen mal
so einen Torten-Rap, der zu mir passt.
>> MURAT: Nein, nein, nein, nein!
Ich will damit nichts zu tun haben. Ich gehe raus wieder.
>> SALLY: Ich lasse hier das mal vor sich brutzeln.
Und dann können wir jetzt gleich
– denn ich möchte ja auch was von Eko lernen.
>> EKREM: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich meine, ich habe dir heute gezeigt,
wie man Zwiebeln schneidet.
>> EKREM: Ja, hast du gezeigt. Ja.
Ja, du kannst ja...
Ich sage ja, es fängt an
– dabei die allergrößte Regel ist:
Du musst authentisch sein.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> EKREM: Deswegen, du musst bei der Wahrheit bleiben.
>> SALLY: Das bin ich. Okay.
>> EKREM: So. Und dann fangen wir an zu reimen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> EKREM: Du brauchst ein bisschen Reim-
>> SALLY: Oh, das kann ich. Deutsch
– Deutschlehrerin.
>> EKREM: Warst du Deutschlehrerin?
Ja, siehst du, das ist wie bei Goethe,
bei den Gedichten.
So. Das heißt, du musst einen Reim finden zum Beispiel.
Was willst du sagen?
>> SALLY: Ich will sagen:
[Musik]
Ich liebe Kuchen und Torten.
>> EKREM: Ich liebe Kuchen und Torten. Okay.
>> SALLY: Davon gibt's verschiedene Sorten.
[Musik]
>> EKREM: Ey!
Ich muss der gar nichts mehr beibringen. Hör mal!
>> SALLY: Okay, mach du weiter.
>> EKREM: Was sagst du?
>> MURAT: Darf ich mich mal kurz übergeben?
>> EKREM: O Gott! Werde ich das hier überleben?
>> MURAT: Genau,
zum Beispiel.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> EKREM: Du kannst auch jetzt
mit einem neuen Reim wieder kommen.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt...
>> EKREM: Manchmal ist es auch ganz gut, wenn du
– jetzt gehen wir schon voll tief in die Materie.
Wenn der Satz, den du sagen willst, als Zweites kommt,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: das ist dann so ein psychologischer Trick.
>> SALLY: Oh ja!
>> EKREM: Das nennt sich Punchline bei uns. Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> EKREM: Das heißt, du öffnest erst mal die Ohren
und beim zweiten bam!
>> SALLY: Ja, so machen wir es.
>> EKREM: Und so lange reimen, bis die...
Weißt du, was ich meine?
>> SALLY: Die Message ist...
>> EKREM: Zum Beispiel sag, was du noch sagen willst.
Was ist ein cooler Satz, den du sagen willst?
>> SALLY: Ein cooler Satz?
Dass man halt davon nicht so viel essen soll.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Irgendwie so:
Aber iss davon nicht zu viel.
>> EKREM: Nicht zu viel, und das ist jetzt unser zweiter Satz.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> EKREM: Okay. Jetzt könntest du sagen:
Und ich bringe noch den Kaiserschmarrn ins Spiel.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Aber iss davon bloß nicht zu viel!
>> EKREM: Genau!
Weißt du, das ist das Ganze schon. Also jetzt kannst du...
>> SALLY: Okay. Also...
>> EKREM: Jetzt kannst du ein Album machen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich backe leckere Kuchen und Torten,
davon ganz viele verschiedene Sorten.
Jetzt bringe ich noch den Kaiserschmarrn ins Spiel,
aber iss davon bloß nicht zu viel!
[Applaus]
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
O mein Gott!
Die kann in deinem Background singen und reimen.
>> EKREM: Ja, gerne.
>> SALLY: Wow!
Und wie heißt die Line?
>> EKREM: Die Punchline.
>> SALLY: Punchline! Habt ihr die Punchline gehört?
>> EKREM: Genau so. Ja.
>> SALLY: Voll!
Voll die Message!
Kann ich Deutschlands erste
Kuchen-und-Torten-Rapperin werden?
>> EKREM: Natürlich kannst du das.
Es gibt nichts, was du nicht kannst.
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> EKREM: Wir sind jetzt hier
– ich habe das jetzt hier einfach dazu gegeben, ja?
>> SALLY: Ja, perfekt!
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Guck mal.
Und das hier karamellisiert jetzt auch so vor sich hin.
Und ich würde sagen,
eins machen wir noch.
Kennst du Jay-Z?
>> EKREM: Ja, klar!
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Dann mache ich Beyoncé und du bist Jay-Z.
Dann kommt jetzt unsere Karaoke-Einheit.
>> EKREM: ... in the making.
Part two,
it's so crazy right now!
>> SALLY: I look and stare so deep in your eyes!
I touch on you more and more every time!
[Musik]
So. Da haben wir es jetzt.
>> EKREM: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich muss mich entschuldigen.
Mein Reis ist sehr matschig.
>> EKREM: Ach was!
Ich mag es matschig.
>> SALLY: Dann probier mal,
>> EKREM: Ich probiere.
>> SALLY: ob es schmeckt.
>> EKREM: Guten Appetit erst mal.
>> SALLY: Guten Appetit.
Nicht, dass ihr denkt, wir essen das alles alleine.
Natürlich dürfen jetzt alle gleich mitessen.
Aber es möchten nicht alle vor die Kamera.
>> EKREM: Ich mag die Soße total.
Passt auch zusammen mit dem türkischen Reis.
Da kann man gar nichts sagen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ist echt so.
>> ELA: Mami, ich will Petersilie.
Mama?
>> SALLY: Magst du noch, bevor wir absetzen,
noch das Dessert probieren?
>> ELA: Mama?
>> EKREM: Super gerne!
>> SALLY: Zur Kostprobe?
[Musik]
Und jetzt noch ein bisschen Kaymak dazu.
>> EKREM: Wow!
Kaymak liebe ich ja auch!
>> SALLY: Oh, ich liebe auch Kaymak!
Das ist so...
>> EKREM: Das Dessert.
>> SALLY: Ja. Probier mal.
>> EKREM: Okay.
>> SALLY: Gut?
Juhu!
Perfekt!
Nach dem Essen lasse ich ihn gleich
noch den San Sebastian Cheesecake probieren.
Aber das müsst ihr jetzt nicht mehr miterleben.
Denn wir wollen uns jetzt alle gemeinsam setzen und essen.
Es war mir echt ein Fest und eine Ehre,
dass du heute mit mir gekocht hast,
mir das Rappen beigebracht hast,
ich gegen dich verloren habe.
Und ich hätte mir echt
keinen besseren Gast wünschen können für die erste Folge.
>> EKREM: Danke schön. Sally, danke für die Einladung.
>> SALLY: Es war mega!
>> EKREM: Ich freue mich mega.
Und jetzt können wir endlich essen!
>> SALLY: Endlich!
Also macht's gut!
Und wenn euch das Video gefallen hat,
dann teilt es auch gerne.
Schreibt drunter, wen ihr vielleicht
als nächsten Gast sehen wollt, auch.
Und auf jeden Fall
müsst ihr euch das Video von ihm anschauen,
das Musikvideo, und auch gerne teilen.
Denn das ist echt eine richtig gute Message.
[Musik]